adriana is with us in san diego hi
adriana how are you
hi thank you for taking my call i have a
question um we
have a hundred thousand dollars saved
and we don't know what to do with it
um we just started listening to your
show a couple months ago so now we're
lost okay um what do you suggest we do
it's a wonderful place to be lost
yeah i'd like to lose myself in a
hundred thousand dollars
not a bad thing yeah so you know what we
teach
is the shortest path from where you are
to wealth
uh and the goal being that when you're
wealthy you have margin in your life you
have the ability to be generous you have
the ability to
uh spend the time doing the things you
want to do
and serving others in the process so
that that's the reason for this whole
thing
and so we teach a thing called the baby
steps so wherever you are on the baby
steps is what i would do with that is
your home paid off
yes sir and you're 100 debt free
um well we owe about 12 000 on the car
and that's it
okay so now we have 88 000 because we
just paid that off
uh do you have an emergency fund other
than this set aside
of three to six months of expenses
um yeah we have a dozen i mean six
thousand dollars a side of that
okay okay so you need to figure out what
three to six months of expenses are
what's your household income about 120.
okay so if we said three months expenses
might be
25 000 we'd set 25 000 in a separate
savings account just
for emergencies i just made that up you
decide what you want to do
you paid off your twelve thousand dollar
car that's thirty seven thousand
uh so that leaves me uh sixty three
thousand dollars to do something with
uh do you have fifteen percent of your
income going into retirement
yes sir good do you have children
yes we have two uh nine and twelve how's
their college funds
um well we're saving for that too we're
doing a separate account for them but i
don't know how much he's in there but
just putting
there i would sit down with your
investment advisor and see if you have
enough
on that already done if you don't we
might use some of that 63
000 for that otherwise you're what we
would call once you've done these other
things you would be at what we call baby
step
7 which is the last step there's nothing
left to do but they're there but build
wealth
and become outlandishly generous and so
uh you know if you don't need any money
for the kids college and so you have the
whole 63 000 available
then you're down to investing that in
some way
uh and or being generous with that money
in some way
and so i personally only do two kinds of
investing
uh i buy real estate that i pay cash for
so no mortgages and i invest in good
growth stock mutual funds
uh 63 000 in san diego will not buy you
real estate and so you'll be investing
in mutual funds
uh you don't have enough to pay cash for
a piece of reasonable piece of real
estate there
uh and i don't recommend long distance
landlording and so
uh in your case 63 000 almost if you
even if you want to buy real estate
later i'm going to invest this for now
in some good mutual funds
with the goal of adding to it over time
to buy some real estate with cash
later on but follow a clear detail path
it's called the baby steps and you can
find it at ramseysolutions.com it's got
everything there
that you need